now I'm going to clear off the screen
here and we're going to talk about the
shape of the sine function let's do that
this is a plot of the sine function
where the angle theta this is the theta
axis in this plot where where theta has
been plotted out on a straight line
instead of wrapped around this circle so
if we draw a line on here let's make
this this circle of radius one so if I
draw this line up here and it's on a
unit circle the definition of sine of
theta this will be theta here is
opposite over hypotenuse so this is the
the opposite side and that distance is
the opposite leg of that triangle is
this value right here so sine of theta
is actually equal to Y over the
hypotenuse and the hypotenuse is one in
all cases around this so if I plot this
on a curve this is an angle and I
basically go over here and plot it like
that and then as as theta swings around
the circle I'm going to plot the
different values of Y if it comes over
this way down here like this right you
can see that that plots over there like
that
now when the angle gets back all the way
to zero of course the sine function
comes all the way back to zero and then
it repeats again as our vector swings
around the other way so the sine of two
pi is zero just like the sine of zero so
every two pi if I go off the screen
every 2 pi comes back and repeats to
zero so now I want to do the same thing
with the cosine function that we did was
sign where we project the projection of
this value onto this time the cosine
curve down here this has the cosine
curve with time going down on the page
and our definition of cosine was
adjacent
over hypotenuse hypotenuse is one in our
drawing so cosine of theta equals
adjacent which is X the x value divided
by hypotenuse which is one so in this
diagram the cosine of theta is actually
the x value which is this X right here
so let me clean this off for a second
and we'll start at the beginning let's
start with the radius pointing straight
sideways and we know that cosine of
theta equals zero is 1 so if I drop that
down if I project that down on to the
angle 0 that's this point right here on
the curve now as we roll forward we go
to a higher angle this projection now
moves to here on the curve when the
arrow is straight up we are at this
point right here we go back through the
axis if we go continue on this projects
down here and
we're moving this
radius vector around in a circle like
this eventually this one will be at the
same point as before as the one above
but it'll be on this part of the curve
here and when we get back to zero again
the projection is to this point here so
that's a way to visualize the cosine
curve getting generated by a vector
rotating around the circle the cosine
comes out the bottom because it's the
projection on the x-axis and when we did
the sine it was the projection on the
y-axis produce the sine wave when we
went this way so I like to visualize
this because this this rotating vector
is a really simple and powerful idea and
we can see how it actually generates
it's a way to generate sines and cosine
waves and you can see how sort of
naturally they come out at different
phases right the sine starts at zero and
the cosine starts at one with this way
of drawing it you can see why that
happens so this relationship between
circles and rotating vectors and sines
and cosines is a very powerful idea
we're really going to take advantage of
this